[MUSIC PLAYING]
PETER-MARK VERWOERD:
Hi, everyone.
My name is Peter-Mark Verwoerd.
I'm a solution architect
for Google Cloud.
I focus on migration solutions
and help customers basically
discover what Google
Cloud is and how to use it
and how to move to it.
BRIAN STARK: Hi.
I'm Brian Stark.
I'm a product manager at
Google Cloud platform.
I'm responsible for
basically the same topic.
[LAUGHTER]
PETER-MARK VERWOERD:
So the two of us
end up talking to
a lot of customers
about how Google
Cloud works for them
and how they can
migrate to Google Cloud
and what are the best
practices, how to do it,
and what are the
motivations and what
are the consequences of that.
So what we'd like to do for the
next hour or maybe a little bit
less is talk to you a
little bit about some
of the common scenarios
and some of the things
that we see in migrations.
Where the title comes from of a
single migrated application is,
I think, a lot of
the time when we
go into customers
I think there is
a bit of an uncertainty to the
scope of the problem, the size
of the problem.
And so we thought
we'd bring it down
to the scale of a
single application.
What does it look like to
do the one application,
because I think that's
much more manageable
and conceptually it's
easier to handle.
So you've made
this big decision.
Yay, we're going to the cloud.
Now what?
You've got a data center.
Inside that data center you
got services, applications,
something somebody wrote
about four years ago.
Nobody knows how it works.
You've got databases
that are running,
storage media that
you're running.
Is that a Solaris box
in the background?
I don't even know
what's going on.
At a certain point
you start feeling
overwhelmed with all the
stuff that's in there.
Do you want to give up?
Do you to just say no?
BRIAN STARK: Stop!
Don't give up.
As it turns out migrating to
the Cloud can be a lot of work,
but it doesn't have to
be overwhelming work.
We've worked with
a lot of customers
in migrating that can be
a straightforward process.
Migration has
parallels to building
a house, which is probably why
we use this analogy so often.
And you're going to
move into this house.
But before you can
move into your house,
you have to put the things
that the house needs,
like a plumbing
and a foundation.
Otherwise, you're just
dropping your furniture
into an empty lot, and
we don't want to do that.
So before we move
into this house,
we need to put in the plumbing.
This is what I like to refer
to as the Google plumbing.
You need to have
a Google account.
You need to create
an organization.
You need to set up the billing.
These are all basics you need
to do before a single VM gets
started.
And while some of this is
Google account related,
there are also some things you
need to decide as a policy.
Of course, the first
thing you need to do
is create a Google
Cloud account.
There's much more to
be done before you
can start moving application.
Let's go into the rest
of this individually.
The most important bit of Google
plumbing to set up is IAM.
IAM can be complicated,
but it basically
comes down to what can you do.
Who can do something?
An identity.
What can they do?
A policy.
To what?
A resource.
It's important to
decide who will be
able to do what when you start.
It may not be exactly
the right kind,
but it's better than
having no policy
and implementing it later.
Extending your analogy is kind
of like installing plumbing
after your house has been built.
It's possible, but it's messy.
So how do we set this up?
PETER-MARK VERWOERD:
This is actually
one of my colleagues,
Vic, very animatedly
talking about the various ways
that customers can actually
set up the various aspects
of the Google plumbing
before they move in.
And I love his animations, so
I shamelessly steal his gif.
So the reality is
there's actually no one
way of doing this precisely.
There's no one formula that
fits every single customer.
But we do offer, when
we speak to customers
who have these kinds of
questions about setting up
before they start
migrating-- so there
are a lot of best practices
that we can recommend.
So going through a few of
these, certainly principle
of least privilege is something
that we preach relatively
constantly to everyone.
The idea of handing out only
what permissions people need
in order to accomplish the
job that they're doing,
rather than handing out
permissions indiscriminately.
You don't want to
necessarily make
all your developers owners
of every single project
or owners of the
entire organization.
You want to kind of restrict
that permission, like ownership
of a development
project or being
able to deploy but not
necessarily to terminate,
all these other things.
Or, for example, like
billing ownership and being
able to determine
where the bill goes
and what projects are billing.
These are important permissions
that you want to appropriately
assign as necessary.
So you don't want to restrict
somebody from doing their job,
but you also don't want
to necessarily give them
more permission than they
need to be able to do it.
Secondly, using groups actually
makes managing permissions
much, much easier than having
to manage individual permissions
on their own.
Having to manage
individual identities
and send out
and switching roles and then
switching what they can do
and what they can't do, it's
operationally more burdensome
and it leads to things
falling through the cracks.
Being able to use groups means
that you can assign permission
to groups.
In long term, these
groups are supposed
to be able to do things--
people come and go
from the groups,
but their permissions
don't move.
So for example, let's say you
had a network security group.
They are responsible for setting
all the firewall rules, all
the networking rules,
when networks are created
and destroyed, and so on.
Rather than assigning
that bit of permission,
those permission
sets to individuals
when they join the
network security team,
you assign that to the group.
People come and go
within that team,
but the permissions
never have to change.
It's a lot less to manage, and
it's a lot less error prone.
Similarly, actually controlling
who can set the policy--
so the watchers of the
watchers as it were--
is very important.
Being able to determine
what group of people
are going to say, yes, these
are the appropriate permissions
for this group of
people, and that's
the appropriate permissions
for that group of people.
It's very important to
be able to manage that
at a very granular level.
You don't want to hand
that kind of permission
out to a lot of
different people.
That should be a
smaller group that
has the authority, that has
the institutional process
and know how as to who
should be assigned to what
and be able to do what.
So it's a very small
group of people,
but you want to make sure
it's fairly restricted.
And another way to increase
your permission setup
before you start
moving to Google Cloud
is to make sure to invest
in looking at audit logs.
This is a part of Stackdriver.
We audit every single
API call that you make.
Look at these audit logs,
start using these audit logs,
and be familiar with
these audit logs,
because you want to
know what is being
done at any given point within
the overall Google environment.
And then this was something
else Brian briefly touched on--
is setting up your organization.
So within Google
Cloud you can use
what we call Cloud
resource manager to be
able to create an
organization that maps
to your literal organization.
So at the top, there
is this concept
of an organizational node
and billing can flow up
and permissions flow down.
And so being able to set
this up from the start,
before you start moving things,
before you start instantiating
virtual machines,
databases, what have you,
is really, really important.
Again, it's the kind of
thing you could do later on,
but it's messy.
And so there are a
couple of different ways
that people take the
organization concept
and decide how to use the
projects underneath it.
I'm going to walk through
three of these really
briefly, because
the first concept is
the easiest one to understand.
All right, we're going to have
one organization, one project,
everyone's going to swim
inside this big pool
of the single project,
and everything
gets deployed in there.
And conceptually that's really
easy to manage and figure out,
but the downside is actually
quotas and permissions
are tied to the project.
So let's say you've
got two teams that
want to use
databases, and you've
allocated quota for
Bigtable to one team,
and the other team
just grabs it first.
Well, within the
construct of the project
there's nothing
really preventing them
from doing that.
So you end up getting a
lot of quota contention
if a lot of different teams
are sharing the same project.
The next option is kind
of to divide up, say,
along divisional lines
or broader groups, which
is a little bit easier.
You get less contention
over resources,
but it kind of fairly
quickly devolves
into what the first
option looks like,
where it's not really
enough separation to make
anyone happy.
What we generally
recommend, and this
is kind of how Google
works, is actually
projects divided up by kind
of the feature or the product
level.
So a product team
or a feature team
would own a particular
project for their own feature
in their own project.
They get quota based on
what they need to do.
They're not sharing
it with other teams.
And that's kind of the level
of ownership that we recommend.
What is also helpful
at this level
is that not only are
quotas divided by products
but permissions.
So permissions can
filter down from the top
and be able to be separated
out at the project level, which
is also very handy for being
able to kind of appropriately
divide up different teams.
So there you go.
BRIAN STARK: And finally,
what considerations
are there for regions?
If you guys watched
this morning,
they announced a whole
bunch of new regions.
We're now up to, I think,
17 is what's been announced.
But there can be regulatory,
political, or policy
reasons why you
don't want to have
your data in certain regions.
Some companies want to
keep their data in the US.
Recently a lot more want
to keep it out of the US.
Some want to have it in the EU,
some don't want it in the EU.
So you need to have a policy
of where applications reside.
You want to be as close to user
base as possible generally,
but you have to deal with
your policy compliance issues.
And you also want to limit
the amount of overhead
in your IT team supporting
multiple regions.
So all of these must
be considered before.
If you don't do this ahead of
time, what's going to happen
is your developers are
going to start picking
and then you'll be
stuck with regions
sprawled all over the place.
PETER-MARK VERWOERD:
All right, Brian.
So we covered everything.
Now we can talk about
migrating something, right?
BRIAN STARK: We're
building a house.
PETER-MARK VERWOERD: Yeah
BRIAN STARK: We put some
pipes in the ground,
and you're ready to move in?
PETER-MARK VERWOERD: Can we not?
BRIAN STARK: No, no.
We're not ready to move
at this point, Peter-Mark.
PETER-MARK VERWOERD: Fine.
BRIAN STARK: We have to
do the next part, which
is the foundation.
It's a concrete slab.
This is what sits on top
of the Google plumbing--
the decisions that come
from your processes
and your company.
What kind of network
are you going to use?
What kind of connectivity do we
have to existing data centers?
What will your developer
workflow look be?
And we need to look
at each of these.
PETER-MARK VERWOERD: So
unlike the product structure
where we generally recommend
that third option where
each team gets
their own project,
the network design is actually
something that could credibly
say that we want to use a bunch
of these different options
or one of them.
This is not one of
those suggestions
where this one is better
and that one is not.
These are all kind of valid.
So the first one that
we're going to talk about
is basically network islands.
And that each project or
each service, whatever it is,
kind of lives within
its own isolated island.
And the only exposure it
has to the outside world
is via an API or some sort
of consumable resource
that other projects, other
consumers, whether they're
internal or external, can hit.
And as far as the rest of the
outside world is concerned
it's a black box.
And so that kind of
connectivity means
that it's a very, very
high level of isolation.
It's limiting the blast
radius for any kind
of issues that come up.
But it also means that it's--
you really need to be
very good at knowing what
your outside consumers,
whether they're colleagues,
whether they are people
internally who are consuming
these resources or externally.
You really need to
know what that is.
Next option is a slight
variation on this--
doing network peering,
where you connect
different networks as necessary,
say, over direct links, though.
So you connect the
network, say, over a VPN.
And this is another model
that we see a lot of,
in particular with companies
that are creating networks
for different groups
inside the cloud
but also want to connect back
to, say, an existing data
center and be able to connect
back to networks there.
This kind of fits in
with the mental model
of what they've already done.
And so we see this a lot, too.
A variation on that is doing
a network hub and spoke,
where, say, shared
services reside inside
of a single network.
Maybe that's where the
connectivity from the office,
or the existing data center,
or whatever the case may be,
is going to land in there.
You've got shared
services like an LDAP
or an ID or something like that.
And then the other networks
that are in the cloud kind
of just phone into
that central network
and consume whatever resources
they need but otherwise sit
in their own isolated network.
And then something
that we actually just
launched publicly today is XPN.
So that stands for
cross project network.
And this is kind
of a variation on--
it's really not a variation
on anything, but--
[LAUGHTER]
If you want all your resources
to reside in the same network,
if you want all
of your projects,
of your features,
if you want all your
services in the same project,
but what you want to avoid is
teams deciding on their own
what are the
network permissions,
what are the actions that
you're allowed to do,
what you're not allowed to do,
where the route is going to go,
and all those sorts of things.
What you can do is
create an XPN network,
where the ownership
of that XPN network
is for a networking team.
They are going to decide
all the permissions.
They're going to decide with the
firewalls look like and so on.
And then they grant permission
to other projects to say,
you are granted permission
to instantiate resources
within this XPN.
And you're going to
own those resources.
You're going to own those
virtual machines and so on.
But you're not going
to own the network.
You're just going to
sit in the network,
and we're going to manage
that network for you.
And so that lets you have
a shared global network
or a shared regional network,
depending on what you want,
without having to
share out permissions
to managing the database
or managing the network.
So next, this is
very much related
to what the network design looks
like, what kind of connectivity
will you have to
existing resources?
So we're talking
about migration.
There's an existing
resource somewhere.
And how do you want
to connect to it?
And I think like
the network design,
there's not a right answer here.
There are just
different options.
So I think one of the first
options that most people think
of is creating a VPN
tunnel, an encrypted site
to site and tunnel
between a data center
and up to Google Cloud.
And I think a lot of
projects start that way.
The next level is leasing
out a line with a partner.
So getting a certain amount
of guaranteed capacity
over a private line
connecting between Google
and yourself is
certainly an option.
And then finally,
actually, what is also
a totally valid option
is companies that say,
you know what?
We've got this stuff
in our data center,
and that's sitting there.
What we're doing is
we are redeploying.
We are moving applications not
by actual transferring of bits,
but actually these
things are just
going to be recreated
in the cloud.
We don't want to have that
connection between our existing
resources and our
ongoing resources.
So there are
different ways to look
at this and different
kind of trade-offs.
And it kind of depends
very much on kind
of what you're looking
for and what you're trying
to get out of a migration.
Also, not all of these
decisions have to be long term.
They don't have to be the last
and final decision on this.
We also see a lot of
customers say, well,
while we're in our
transition phase,
we're going to
actually lease out
a lot of capacity between
our data center and Google.
So we can transfer
things more quickly,
we can have a wider
pipe into Google Cloud.
And then after we're
done, actually, we're
just going to turn it off.
So you have two, three,
six months, 12 months,
whatever the case may
be of a lease line,
and then you turn
it off afterwards.
And then, finally, what does
this look like for developers
as they use the cloud?
So if you consider
a company when
leadership has
made the decision,
yes, we're moving
to Google Cloud.
We're happy for
all these reasons.
We've made our decision.
Operations knows about all this.
Say, OK, well, data
centers are closing down
for whatever reason.
We're moving to cloud.
There's a very good chance,
especially as organizations
grow, that not every developer
is going to know about this.
Not every developer is going
to be in on every discussion,
every decision.
They're carrying on.
They're doing their job.
They're fixing bugs,
creating features,
releasing new products,
whatever the case may be.
They're not part
of this process.
And so understanding
that point of view
and making sure that developers,
when they move to the cloud,
have a particular
workflow that makes sense.
And then this really,
again, comes down
to what a company wants to do.
How do you want to make that
workflow for your developers,
essentially internal customers?
Are you going to
keep it the same
and try to make all the
changes on your own back-end
so that whatever tooling they
use seems kind of seamless?
Like, oh, I used to be deploying
to a San Francisco data center,
and now I'm deploying
to US central,
otherwise my life is the same?
Or are you saying,
you know what?
We're taking this chance.
We're going to change
everything that we did.
We don't like the old system.
Here is the new system.
We're going to do that.
And these all come with kind
of varying levels of effort
and operational
overhead depending
on where you want to go.
If you want to do
a lot of homework
for your operations team to
make it easier for feature
developers, you can do that.
Or if you want to
say, you know what?
We're all in the same boat.
We're making this
big transition.
Feature developers are going
to help out the operations team
as well--
and varying levels of
effort in between there.
So if you're not already
using some sort of automation
pipeline, if you're not
using continuous integration,
continuous deployment, this is
actually a great opportunity
to start using it, because it
makes migrations much, much,
much easier.
If you're already using it,
please continue to do so.
I'm sure you've already noticed
that it makes your life easier.
And then finally with
compute, what we like to say
is when doing a
migration, don't try
to change everything at once.
So try to do something like
for like as much as possible.
So if you're running
on bare metal,
if you're using virtualized
machines, continue to do that.
Use virtual machines and
try to compare or find
comparable versions
among instance types.
But I think one thing
that's important to look
at when you do that is look
at the actual resources you're
consuming on a virtual machine
rather than ones that you have.
So if you've got a
64 core box that's
running whatever application,
but you're actually
only at like 10% CPU usage, you
may not need a 64 core machine.
And then finally, if
you're using containers,
please, again,
continue to do so.
We like them a lot.
They run pretty well.
All right, Brian, that's
got to be it, right?
BRIAN STARK: We've got
pipes and a foundation.
PETER-MARK VERWOERD: Yeah.
BRIAN STARK: And
you want to move on?
PETER-MARK VERWOERD: Yeah.
BRIAN STARK: So you're
on the sales team, right?
PETER-MARK VERWOERD: Yes.
BRIAN STARK: OK.
On the engineering
side of the house,
we like to do a little bit more.
No, you're not ready to move.
PETER-MARK VERWOERD: Man.
Fine.
[LAUGHTER]
BRIAN STARK: Yeah.
So we've built the plumbing
and the foundation, Peter-Mark.
But the first application
needs to be selected.
What's going to move
into the house first?
In theory, it could be anything.
And there's a lot
of different points
of view over what the first
thing you should move is.
I've talked to
some customers that
say it's only exciting when you
move the hardest thing first.
I don't encourage that.
A lot of people prefer something
that's a little bit cleaner
and is going to create less
disruption in the business.
So I'll talk about
commonalities--
not guarantees of what's
kind of a good, easy thing
to move first.
Generally you want
something that
has few if any dependencies.
It's not talking to like
30 or 50 different machines
within the data center.
You want something that's
running Linux or Windows
and fairly modern.
If you're running Red
Hat 4 or Windows 2003,
that's probably
not where you want
to start in terms of getting
your application over to Cloud.
And then this is surely
just recommendation, take it
for what it's worth--
internal can be
better than external.
Most companies would prefer
to aggravate their employees
than their customers.
So if you want to move
an internal system that's
cut inward facing and
see if that works--
it tends to be a
little bit better place
to start than just your
web facing property.
PETER-MARK VERWOERD: All right.
I know you're going
to tell me no,
but we've got to be
ready to move now, right?
I mean, what else is there?
BRIAN STARK: We're ready.
PETER-MARK VERWOERD: Oh.
BRIAN STARK: You made it.
PETER-MARK VERWOERD: Finally.
BRIAN STARK: You've
been so eager,
but we finally got there.
PETER-MARK VERWOERD: I know.
I just want to move.
BRIAN STARK: We got the house.
All right.
So as long as you're running
a supported operating system
you should be fine.
As long as this
is one application
it should be relatively
straightforward.
If you've got the CI/CD pipeline
that Peter-Mark talked about,
that's awesome.
You can just redeploy to
a new target Google Cloud.
We just announced our
VM migration service,
so that's an awesome way
to move virtual machines
or physical machines if
you want to go that way
and just copy the
machine into the Cloud.
It makes things pretty easy
in terms of a migration.
If the application
has a database,
move that at the same time.
You're only doing one move
here, so the prudent thing
is to pause the application,
pick a downtime window,
and just go slow and go
gradual and don't rush it.
If you guys get a
chance to talk to Lush,
I think they moved
their entire website
in the course of 22 days.
I don't encourage that.
It's an option, but it leads
to long nights and stress.
Yeah, I'm going to give you
some best practices here.
They're not in any
particular order.
We put them down in the
way we thought to be best.
So first stage is
the migrations.
Try to schedule it.
Try to have a defined period
you're going to do this in.
Don't try to rush this out
on artificial deadlines.
Take your time and
do it correctly
as opposed to forcing it.
Create clear goals for your
migrating team, define success.
Make it very clear
what you're trying
to achieve so that when
you've done the migration
you can say this was successful
or this was not successful.
And then you may wish
to offer guidance
on what kind of
instance types to use,
what kind of storage
products and databases.
Typically you're going to find
your team isn't particularly
familiar with Cloud.
So it's going be critical
that you give some guidance.
And then as you
develop this expertise,
make sure the teams
are transferring it
from one to the
next so you don't
have to reinvent the
wheel every time you
try to move an
additional application
within your business.
As Peter-Mark mentioned,
deployment tooling-- it's
a great idea.
If you don't have it, get it.
It will make your life a
lot easier on the long term.
The businesses we see moving
really fast in migration
have this capability in place.
It certainly helps.
And then monitoring tooling--
so just kind of a pro-tip here.
If you're going to
monitor something,
don't host it on the same
service you're monitoring--
in case anyone
followed last week.
But generally if you're going
to have something, monitor it.
We have stacked driver.
It's a great tool.
There's lots of them out there.
But if you're going
to be in the Cloud,
have that set up as part
of the migration as well.
And then finally, test
after you migrate.
Make sure it's all working
and have some definition
of what working means to you.
And now let's look at what
it means to move data.
Just some basic rules again,
not in any particular order.
Data size-- it's
kind of obvious,
but in some ways it isn't.
Data size dictates difficulty.
The bigger it is and the
smaller your bandwidth, the more
challenge you're going
to have moving data.
Relational schemas
tend to be easier, too.
Things you're not
using very often
are easy to move as
well because you're
dealing with the fast
incremental updates.
Large data sets
require planning.
If you're going to move--
Evernote mentioned moving
70 petabytes or 30 petabytes
in 70 days.
That requires a lot of planning.
You don't just show
up and do that.
There's only so much you
can push over the wires.
There are only so many
trucks you can bring up
to your data center.
And we like to look at
this chart as just a way
to think about it.
To understand the
scale of the problem
there is some basic math here.
So if you're going to
move 100-- if you're
going to move 100 terabytes,
roughly 25 hard drives,
over a 100 megabyte wire, it's
going to take you 124 days.
If you can use
Cloud interconnect
and get a 10 gigabyte
per second link,
that same time is 30 hours.
And Just a dramatic
difference in terms
of your ability to move things.
This is up on the
Google Cloud website
if you guys want to
look at it and just get
a sense of the scale of the
problem you're taking on.
PETER-MARK VERWOERD: Yeah.
So in case you're
curious about this chart,
this is available on--
there's a solution actually
that was relatively recently
released maybe a month ago.
So it was transferring
big data sets to GCP.
We literally just stole
it from that page.
But then there's a whole lot
of detail about how that works
and different strategies and
advice on how to do that.
BRIAN STARK: It's probably
important to evaluate
the different storage
options within the Cloud.
If you're not
familiar with Cloud,
it can be a little
bit daunting at first.
It was for me when
I joined Cloud.
And just because you use
a certain data type today
doesn't mean you should use that
going forward in the future.
So just understand
the different options
between block an
object and the others,
and understand what it means
for you from a performance
perspective, and then understand
what it means from a cost
perspective as well.
And then consider the data
structure you're moving to.
So if you change
your storage, just
be aware what the
differences are
and how that's going to
impact your application.
PETER-MARK VERWOERD: Can I
just stop you for one second?
So this is actually a question
that comes up quite a bit
when we are helping
customers move.
This is what we're using today,
what does that translate to?
We are using MySQL.
We're using Postgres.
We're using Cassandra.
How does that map to--
what do I take here
that maps directly to here?
And sometimes there's
an easy answer.
Well, if you're using MySQL,
you can continue to use MySQL.
That's fairly straightforward.
But sometimes it's
not an easy answer.
If you say we have 15
Cassandra clusters,
what should I move it to?
The answer is probably
not any one thing.
It's not necessarily
going to be Bigtable.
going to be Spanner
or whatever the case may be.
And so finding out and
figuring out where data moves
can be one of the harder
parts of a migration.
The actual mechanics of
doing it is actually--
it can often be
not that difficult.
It's the decision process
that is much more difficult.
And so I think most of
Google, like database products
in particular-- if you go
from CloudSQL to Datastore
or Bigtable, Spanner
and BigQuery in certain
circumstances--
I think they have well
defined use cases,
but they also have
cross-over use cases
where there's a bit of
a gray area in between.
Where you think, well, I've
got a database that is,
let's say, not
really relational.
I think it could probably fit
into Datastore or Bigtable.
Which one should I use?
And sometimes the
answer was, well,
you probably could use both.
And figuring out which one
is actually the best one
comes down to a few
different factors.
It usually comes
down to how much
are you going to spend on it,
where is it most optimized,
how are you going to use it
for this particular use case?
But we often get questions like,
what is the direct mapping?
Exactly how does
this map into that?
What is the one thing?
And more often than not
there is not the one thing.
There is a few things
that could work.
So it really does take
actual evaluation and testing
of the particular system to
find out what works best.
BRIAN STARK: Thanks.
Every now and again
you make great sense.
I appreciate you chiming in.
PETER-MARK VERWOERD:
So that's it, right?
There's nothing else, right?
BRIAN STARK: No.
Eager beaver.
PETER-MARK VERWOERD: OK.
Fine.
Maybe I'll talk
about other things.
So we touched on this a
little bit in best practices
in terms of actually
finishing a migration.
A lot of the
customers that I talk
to when we kind of talk
through this particular flow,
and we do actually talk
about this quite a bit--
is I often say, you're not done
migrating until you actually
do tests, because you don't
really know what you've done
or that you've been
successful at what
you've done until you test it.
And so certainly, unit tests--
if you're not doing them,
you should absolutely
be doing them.
But run those once
they're in there,
make sure things are working.
Then functional tests--
have somebody sit down
and say, OK, well, this is
how our web app used to work.
This is how it works now.
Great.
It works.
Keep using it.
Or-- oh, no, it
broke at like step 3.
What happened?
We thought we set
it up the same way.
Test it and make sure that it
actually works before you say,
yeah, I'm done.
And then I think something
that people often forget
is actually load testing.
So let's say you have this
web application that's
capable of supporting
like 10,000
concurrent connections in
your existing infrastructure.
Port it over.
Yes, it passes unit tests.
Yes, it passes functional tests.
It's working the same way.
Let it go to production.
And then a half hour
into real users using it,
you realize that
it only supports
10 concurrent
connections not 10,000.
And that's a big difference,
and that's a big problem.
So you don't really
know if it's working
until you figure out what its
performance capabilities are.
And so a dramatic change
like that would mean probably
there's some sort of
configuration problem
or something like that.
But you want to figure
that out before you say,
release it to production.
Say, yeah, this is ready to go.
We're comfortable with that.
And then finally-- not
finally, I'm sorry.
Monitoring-- again, Brian
touched on this a little bit.
We see a lot of companies come
in essentially flying blind.
And if you're not monitoring,
if you're not using some sort
of tool-- whether
it's Stackdriver,
whether it's your own tool,
whether it's a third party
tool--
there's no real way
to kind of figure out
how things are moving and
how things have been done.
So you really don't
know that you're done.
You don't know that
the application
is working unless
you can actually
monitor what it's doing.
And again, this is
actually critical.
This is essential to
finishing a migration,
because you don't
know it otherwise.
And then finally that
alerting is great,
but it's not enough unless
you're actually getting--
the monitoring is great.
It's not enough unless
you're getting alerts
based on what happens.
So if you're
monitoring everything,
and you're monitoring
the right things,
and the monitors go
all the way to 100%,
because you're
using too much CPU,
you filled up your
disk or whatever it is,
and nothing happens
because of that--
that's kind of
only half the work.
You have to be able
to alert on that.
You have to be able to tell
people this is becoming bad.
The situation is getting worse.
Action needs to be taken.
Somebody needs to
take care of that.
So alerting and monitoring
really very much
go hand-in-hand.
And too often we see
kind of only half
of that solution in there.
So how about now?
Are we done?
BRIAN STARK: For
now I think we are.
PETER-MARK VERWOERD: Yeah?
What comes next?
Well, you get the clicker
is what comes next.
[LAUGHTER]
BRIAN STARK: How about
a larger migration?
You ready for the next one?
Seriously, migrations
can be difficult.
They can be involved.
They can be lengthy.
But they don't have
to be complicated.
Whether your moving one
application or 1,000,
the general path is the same.
PETER-MARK VERWOERD:
And so this is something
that we've seen-- oh, sorry.
BRIAN STARK: No, no.
It's a basic process.
You pick applications.
You move applications.
You move data--
rinse and repeat.
PETER-MARK VERWOERD: Yeah.
BRIAN STARK: You'll
get through it.
PETER-MARK VERWOERD:
And so this is something
that we talk about over and
over with different customers.
And the reason why--
again, this is why this topic
is moving a single application
rather than moving
hundreds of applications.
Because actually the
workflow is the same,
and this is what we see.
So you take whatever
snapshot of what
you have to move that makes
sense inside of your head,
whether it's moving
the whole thing,
subsections, teams,
single applications at a time.
It actually is pretty much the
same process over and over.
Sorry.
I stepped all over you.
BRIAN STARK: But
at the end you're
going to end up with
a beautiful house.
So thank you, guys, very much.
[MUSIC PLAYING]